[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui devant un restaurant
italien qui s'appelle d'arauco voilà qui
est juste là pour parler de samsung
parler des nouveaux produits alors on va
parler tablette on a parlé smartphone ya
pas longtemps avec le galaxy à 50 ans
aujourd'hui parler des nouveaux de tabe
tab est 5e et tab à je propose c'est
qu'on y va comme ça vous regarde et vous
verrez c'est très intéressant et le spot
si vous le connaissez pas il est juste
ou faux c'est magnifique ça va commencer
avec tomates samsung alors thomas ya de
la nouveauté
toutes les sommes tous au niveau de la
tablette tout à fait de nouveaux
produits tu peux me les présente et
c'est pourquoi bien évidemment un grand
plaisir
nous avons deux nouveautés sata bessac
et la table à ok cool quels sont ces
produits à qu'ils détenaient qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec euros
tv5 c'est le peuple partenaire parfait
pour celui qui adore se consommer du
multimédia d'accord elle est fine
elle est légère elle a une superbe
qualité d'écran way est une qualité
audio top
vous êtes vraiment poursuite qui
consomment du multimédia et qui a envie
d'avoir une
support impeccable ont visionné ses
séries préférées l'accord donc tu vas
voir toutes les séries tout on
multimédia youtube netflix sérieuse
puisque tu veux l'être sans problème
exactement
jeannie a d'ailleurs on en parlera tout
à l'heure d'un partenariat avec os x
dans cette tablette school est alors la
table à la tabac c'est plutôt la
tablette pour la famille d'accord elle
est jolie
ouais les qualités en revêtement en
aluminium une belle surface d'affichage
mais c'est effectivement on va retrouver
l'indispensable pour un usage familial
[Musique]
entame de deux écrans de tailles d'écran
de stupéfiants qu'au terme de produit on
y commande être sur la table 5
ouais on a un surface d'affichage de 82%
on peut le voir c'est un écran
panoramique elle utilise la technologie
super amoled avec une définition de 2560
par 1600 donc c'est une format 16/10 est
une très belle luminosité à 508 galaxy
tab à diagonale de 10,1 pouces en
résolution 1960 par 1200 format 16/10
donc vraiment un écran panoramique qui
permet de profiter d'une surface
d'affichage de 80% du produit ou c'est
vraiment idéal pour visionner une vidéo
voir des photos utiliser le mot dans
l'espace enfants qui permet
effectivement de de contrôler les
contenus des plus jeunes
en termes de performances comment on est
à l'intérieur les deux tablettes sont
équipées d'un processeur hopscore
d'accord qui est cadencé à 2 giga watts
à bessens et un verger c'est bon pour la
tabac lattaf à soignies wake qui équipe
déjà les mobiles est présente sur ta
baisse 5 et à bas coût retrouve les
icônes qui sont exactement identiques à
ceux des mobiles la navigation du
panneau de contrôle davantage de when
you elle sait qu'on peut tout faire qui
on à l'intégrité la surface d'affichage
qui est utilisée on n'a pas une petite
fenêtre
ici on devait comme ça
petit peu c'était un peu plus
constructif alors que là on a vraiment
un confort de navigation grossesse avec
ici la possibilité de voir en replay
direct la grille tv au cias est inclus
avec ta table est 5 e pour la tablette 5
effectivement nous avons une offre de
lancement à partir du 12 avril jusqu'au
31 mai avec la possibilité pour le
consommateur qui achète la galaxy tab
est d'avoir trois mois offert à ocs cool
et pouvoir bénéficier donc en
exclusivité puisque à partir du 15 avril
la dernière saison de game of thrones
sera disponible à profiter de cette
dernière série en ait suscité sur sa
table et 5h et évidemment profité pour
ceux qui ont envie de se mettre à jour
deux des saisons précédentes qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on peut appeler des
galaxies bugs également facilement
voilà il suffit d'ouvrir le boîtier des
galaxies bottes et vous voyez cette
fenêtre automatiquement se présenter et
vous pouvez ensuite connecter vos
produits et pour tout ce qui va être
usée standard familiale c'est des choses
qui vont suffisamment orléans
l'alimentent aura pas effectivement il
ya aura aucun souci de fluidité lit pour
le gaming sur ces deux tablettes ok
elles sont d'ailleurs équipés de 4 gigas
ou si giga drame suivant les versions de
stockage sur la table 5 et 2 gigas de
ram sur la table un côté plus multimédia
familial pour les personnes présentes
vision sur la table est 5e et sur la
table ah c'est le produit j'irai pour
rentrer dans l'univers tablette chez
samsung exactement ok pouvons
effectivement on a une solution pour
ceux qui souhaitent découvrir
univers tablettes et pouvoir partager
sud hier à toute la famille c'est des
produits qui sont déjà disponibles ou
qui vont l'être bientôt alors c'est aux
tablettes vont être lancées le 12 avril
donc surtout proche laquelle tarifs
alors le tarif
nous sommes sur la tabac wifi à 219
euros
d'accord est sur la table est 5e à 419
euros également wifi mais quand il ya
également une possibilité d'avoir une
version 4g voilà c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui en dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous regarde le restaurant
derrière enfants comment vous les
trouvez une seule nouvelle tablette
samsung est ce que ça vous intéresse
vous avez déjà des produits samsung
tablette est ce que vous avez une
tablette et qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces nouveaux produits ce qui pourrait
vous bottez pas vous intéresser oui non
l'ugtt a marqué tout ça en bas en
commentaire on reste connectés via les
visionner ma playlist vous découvrirez
tous les produits qui sortent en ce
moment smartphones tablettes compagnie
il ya plein de choses voilà vous envoie
deux matches
[Musique]